so what happens here is that first we
take 0 and x1 and concatenate that makes
a lock at 0 and x1 are vampire raisins
and after that we offer for my future
future union we perform a theater Union
defining the single best feature and
also taking the first two principal
components after that we construct a
random forest producer and then that we
make a pipeline combining all of these
things together and then we run a fit
and predicting all the regular things
with usually now if we look at this if
we look at the outcomes in the
intermediate steps we'll see just many
numbers so for example if you look at x0
it's basically just a bunch of numbers
inside an untiring
x1 is also a bunch of diamonds and
concatenate them together to prove
several more numbers and if we try to
look at the the outcome of this and look
at our scada feature reports and
services it just gives us another bunch
of numbers and that's a bit of a problem
because it's very difficult sometimes to
interpret what these are numbers means
future importances and we see that you
got these numbers 0 1 0 0 0 so to which
a original feature so next through an
exponent didn't even monitor and given
that the first of these is select a path
which was a kind
the next one so do we even know if it's
been taken very hard to understand what
these internet switches and even more
than assaulted something about 212
must've everything working directly so
there's a you think that I want surveyed
it could be that in the training what
you kind of vista x0 and x1 comfort two
different databases and lovely mountain
concatenate on the train your mama but
once you have your model fitted and want
to deploy it and then the data's coming
down somehow is different entirely maybe
it's coming from you Internet and you
just take it and I'm not predicting
anything because because ESPE learn
basically we'll just check up for
dimensions and as long as the dimensions
fit it's it's okay that I buy it but it
has no way of knowing if you've
concatenated the columns directly and
you might make a mistake there in
slipping around
it'll be just happy with what you get it
in prediction which might not make sense
at all the second example I'd like to
give is a case where you need to perform
data mining in the middle of the car
park so here is a matrix of the classic
movie recommendation system this is a
data from an actual fuel of Serbia
with my three daughters of president and
in this case what we'd like to do is to
run a grid search a CD and a niche fault
of the grid search STV would like to
perform pen and X non-negative matrix
factorization followed by a random
forest depressor so SK learn is an
excellent library and it gives assisted
extent it performs IMF but the problem
is that this matrix is not in the form
where we can apply the NFF directed so
what we need to do is as follows we take
the original matrix which has a column
producer a column for a movie and a
column for the reading and then we need
to pivot it so that the rows are users
and the column to the movies right and
once we've done that only then can we
feed it back and can we feed it into the
NMS step and the NS that will give us
the latent variables explaining the
users and and the movies but actually
this and somehow concatenated and only
after we've done this concatenation that
we have the matrix in the form and we
can pass it on from
so SK learn is an excellent cell library
but it's elaborate from machine learning
it's not a library for data munching at
all I think nothing that will help us do
this really and in some respects of the
problem is that I ask you learn how
basically wasn't even built for
understanding metadata sq learn hasn't
even though for understanding metadata
so if we look at the columns of explain
who are the users and movies okay so the
problem is that the user and the movie
columns are not really describing data
at all they're describing metadata Eskew
learner doesn't really know how to in
fact
SK learn can't even take columns that
take things that are act numeric so
there was a pooling it by somehow
encoding this and numerical values and
then which is orthogonal to the first
two is the combination of verbosity so
here you can see graphically the the
result of taking a select K best
together with PCA and fitting fitting it
in into random a random first regressor
and to me it looks like the following
piece of call of code is just too long
they're not readable enough compared to
what a basically simple thing is being
done here so fortunately all that's
needed is really to built and connect
together things that other people have
done already for the first thing an
empire array is basically just an array
of numbers that Python does have de
facto standard construct for for tabular
data together with metadata that's
that's basically P and s I think it's
used sort of universally so here we can
look at how the iris the metadata sorry
how the iris dataset looks our first in
numpy form and then in pandas form and
in pandas form it's much more clearer
what we're seeing here the second thing
in regards to combinations is that the
unix pipeline has for many years a
system where you can type things from
one stage to another using the pipe
operator and that's very succinct and
and easy to work with so now in the next
two sections I'd like to describe a
library which we've built that addresses
these two things first I'll describe the
interface then a little bit about the
implementation which will be a bit more
more python oriented so the library is
built of two levels there's a low level
which which you shouldn't need to use
most of the time which basically
contains a mixin and an adapter and then
there's the higher level that
automatically wraps all of SK learn and
x/g boost and Center flow so let's start
with a lower level it just contains a
function and mixin it works out this way
suppose you take an SQL and compliant
stage for example you take a scalar and
linear model linear regression and you
call the frame function so what it'll do
is to devise a try
I'm a new class that subclass is both
the original class that you've given it
and the mixin ibex a-frame mixin and
this give this resulting class that
subclasses both of them gives us two
things for for the one it understands no
metadata so it takes only pandas
dataframes in series it outputs only
their pandas the pandas dataframes in
series for example if we fit it on the
matrix X which is indexed by zero one
two and Y which is indexed by 0 1 2 and
we fit it and then we ask it to predict
what will be X so it'll give us a series
not an empire array and it's indexed and
on 0 1 & 2 because we're saying those
are the predictions for the these
specific instances and likewise it also
does this for columns so for example if
we give it x & y where now the columns
let's focus on the columns the columns
of X are a and B and we fitted on x and
y and then then we ask it to predict x
but we invert the the order of the
columns then since logically a data
frame is closed under permutations of
the columns then it doesn't care that
the columns are in the wrong order it'll
output the thing that we expect it to do
because the columns now carry the
metadata and another thing it'll do
though is to check the consistency of
the indices so for example suppose now
we try to repeat it that repeat what
we've done before but we feed it the we
feed at the matrix X which is indexed by
IJ and K and y which is indexed by 21 22
and 23 so obviously something has gone
wrong here right because what are these
instances are the letters instances or
number of instances if who try to do
this then it'll raise an exception
saying that it'll throw an exception
saying that that it doesn't understand
what we want to do and likewise in terms
of columns if we feed it x and y where X
has the columns a and B and we fit it on
that and then we try to predict X 1
which has the columns m and M then it'll
raise an exception and say that it
doesn't understand what these columns
mean it's obviously now operating on
different features then it's been
trained on
here again is the iris dataset in pandas
form so if we take now in an S we see a
scalable sorry support vector classifier
and we ask to fit it and then we ask
what are the coefficients then we won't
get an umpire array instead we'll get a
fan the Stata frame and I think this
pandas dataframe is much more
interpretive all we can see that the
coefficient of of Seto's sepal length
for example is in the top-left corner so
we don't really have to guess anymore
what we got the second thing that the
resulting class which subclasses these
two classes gives us is the optional
ability to combine estimators in a way
that is more succinctly
instead of calling may make pipeline
it's possible now just to use the
horizontal bar the pipe symbol and and
this does exactly the same thing frame
PCI and components to piped into the
following stages is exactly the same as
calling megapack line and similarly
instead of calling make Union we can
optionally use the plus we can actually
optional use the plus sign so combining
these things if we look at the previous
example that we've seen of taking taking
a feature union of select K best and PCA
and feeding it in to a random first
regressor so now we can just write it
very succinctly like this it's the
addition of the first two features piped
into the last estimator and in
conjunction these things work even
better together if we use the metadata
together with combining many many
different steps so for example if we
take again the iris data set in the data
frame form and now we perform pca plus a
select k best and then we do transform
an a so it'll tell us that the result is
a PCA which is which has component 0 and
component 1 and select K best which in
this case chose pedal length in
centimeters so pendous is really good
about all of this hierarchical data it
knows how to organize it so so this just
basically works here
and taking taking the example that we've
seen before suppose we take select hey
best in PCA and we feed it into the
forest and then after fitting it we ask
the forest what are the future
importances so instead of just giving us
numbers that will give us a panda series
and it'll say sepal length was a 0.09
and and it gives names to all the rest
of the things another problem we
encountered before is what to do if we
want is to write a stage that does
pandas manipulation in itself when when
we saw the movie recommend the
recommender system what we needed to do
is perform pivots and merges and all
sorts of stuff like that but in this
case there's not really a problem
because if you write a class on your own
and you just subclass ibex dot frame X n
then all of the methods fit predict and
so on they will just take now data
frames not series and when in the
internal body of the code now that you
have data frames you can use all of the
regular kind s goodness that that you're
used to so I think it's a good way to
combine combine all of these things ok
the second layer basically automatically
wraps SK learn tensor flow an extra
boost for now and it's necessary for the
following crease and as we've seen
before we can use the lower level a
frame function to wrap up things so if
we take select K best and call frame
then we can get a result and if we call
in your regression and apply to it frame
then we can get a result and each time
we call frame we can get another class
but that's a bit tedious it can get
pretty annoying to have someone use
frame over and over again so in order to
in order to avoid this the library
basically automatically wraps of
aforementioned libraries so all you need
to do is instead of importing sq learn
linear model you can import instead of
it ibex SK learns that linear model and
then then you'll just get there all the
regular estimators you're used to but
there will be in a data frame form in
pandas form and the same thing for extra
boost and for
tensorflow in fact you can import
simultaneously in the code both
classical SK learn and ibex SK learn
they really don't bother each other so
this doesn't break any of the code it
doesn't modify any of vascular and they
work well side by side okay now in the
last section what I'd like to do is to
discuss a little bit of the
implementation of it at this point it
becomes a bit more of a pair of Python
talk than I don't know machine learning
or cycle instead of talk so how do we
really write a library that wraps up
estimators the way SK learned us so the
straightforward the straightforward
approach is just to use a composition
right so for example suppose we have
some base estimator and now we'd like to
write a wrapper on top of it so we dried
a class wrapper which takes base
estimator regressor mixin and the frame
xn and inside it'll inside it'll hold an
object of the original thing that it's
wrapping and then then basically it'll
just delegate everything to the internal
object right so the internal object
knows to talk numpy and the external
object we want needs to speak pandas and
it'll work as follows suppose the user
calls us something like predict so it
calls predict and sends it over to the
wrapper class the wrapper class will
validate things it'll it'll check that
it's the appropriate type that it's a
data frame and and the series and so on
after that it'll strip it'll strip all
of the metadata out and just retain the
numpy arrays and send them over to the
wrapped class the rep class will return
a result and then the wrapping class
will add again the necessary indices and
stuff and send things back to the user
so that's that's the way I thought of
approaching it in the beginning but this
really didn't turn out to be so feasible
for a number of reasons the first reason
is that psychic learn is just too big a
library and it's too dynamic a library
this is a code flower type
representation of psychic learning in
the verse
the time you think and you can see here
that there dozens of different classes
and moreover its dynamic each time you
upgrade the version of SCI code learned
and some modules and classes are added
and some are removed and so on so it's
not really possible to to wrap it on one
side and then shape it and and have it
done on the other side so the way to
approach it is to do these things at
runtime so it goes as follows
here's an interesting thing at least for
me about Python when you write a
compound import statement meaning if you
write something like import ibex SK
learner model so the runtime environment
is going to translate this into a series
of import calls so first it's going to
call import ibex
after that it's going to call import
ibex SK learn at this point we can do
something nice that the runtime
environment lets us do which is to
register a class in sis meta path so the
way this works is that we can take a
certain loader class and go to sis meta
path and install it as something that
from now on things need to run through
it once an import is called so after
this is done when the runtime resumes
its import and calls the the full length
of import ibex sq learn linear model
then basically it's running through our
class which which intercept it and at
this point the class is going to use the
SCI code learned installed on that
system and colder and the directory is
going to return the list of all the
members and then we can see here for
example that it that it has the all
variable and ard regression and so on
and so on some of these things are
functions and some are classes which we
want to wrap and some are not and
another useful model to use is inspect
so the way inspector goes is that you
can take all sorts of stuff and ask is
this thing a class is this thing a
function a variable and and so on and
once the runtime tells us what is in the
specific sq learn linear
the system in which it's running now and
inspect can filter out the things that
we want to wrap then then we actually
perform the wrapping and that's way it
works basically for every system
differently okay another thing that's a
bit unique to Secord line is that it's a
bit finicky about its constructor so for
example you cannot write a psychic learn
stage whose init function takes arcs and
kW arcs if you try to do this then the
runtime of circular and wallah complaint
so it's not that easy to write a generic
wrapping class another thing that's a
bit unique to
scikit-learn is that it has attributes
that get added while it's executing so
for example if you take a linear
regression stage and you try to call the
co f attribute then it'll tell you that
it doesn't have any such thing but if
you do fit and then try to call the co f
attribute so it'll say are great I'll
give you now the attribute so you can't
really scan the the class once you load
it and ask it what attributes do you
have it depends what you do with it as
you do with it different operations then
various attributes will be added so
there are several ways of dealing with
it but the way we chose to do it is by
using a local classes so for example
let's look here at a line one at the
logistic regression class and the
logistic regression class has two things
that are unique for to it the first is
it has an initializer that's very
specific to it it takes penalty equals L
to do a legal fall so all sorts of stuff
like that
different estimators will have different
initializer arguments and the same thing
is that at some point in the code it
says self dot and a tour equals
something once you've fitted it it's
willing to tell you how many iterations
it took so our code takes this estimator
and it builds a local class in the local
class the who's code is written inside
the function basically derives from this
estimator and the frame of mixin but it
doesn't supply its own initializer so
now when you try to instantiate this or
to call an iterable things fall down to
the base class and they drop through to
the base class and this way they're
handled appropriately to the class that
that was used to call this stuff
action using local functions has its own
problems I did not notice at the time
but you cannot pickle classes that are
not that are defined locally within the
function so if you try to run this code
the function foo and lower case inside
makes a new class called foo with an
upper case and you try to take this in
to pickle it and the runtime will tell
you that it's not willing to do that
and this isn't Justin as a tech problem
because each time and secord learn you
use a higher order function for example
crossbell score and you send you sent it
some estimator and then it's going to
pickle it and the reason is that
Crossville score and all the other
cross-validation and and so on functions
they have the ability to work on
different processes and the only
basically the only way in python to get
things to work in a truly multi-threaded
way or across different processes is to
try to pickle stuff and and to send them
over to the other processes so because
of that pickling is not not exactly an
esoteric thing so another nice thing
that the Python runtime gives us or
actually it's the Python data model in
this case is the reduce function the
reduce function is a special method that
a class can provide which says what is
the way it would like to be serialized
so basically this function returns all
the code that explains how to wrap it in
each time so each time it's serialized
and this I realized and it has exactly
the information that it needs to
reconstruct itself over and over there
are a few other problems for example
local class names the names of classes
defined inside functions are pretty ugly
if in the interpreter you try to ask
what the name is you've got a gibberish
string and there's also a problem in
partially overwriting attributes so if
you call some of the estimators then
some of their attributes are needed
inside in order to function well and and
socket learn expects these attributes to
be in the form of nampara arrays but on
the other hand in terms of the interface
we would like them to be at the same
time
pandas entities data frames and series
so there's a problem of partially
overwriting attributes like saying when
the class needs to use this attribute
and it should be one thing but when the
user would like to see what the
attribute is then then it should be
something else and there are lots of
lots of hacks to solve this and it
basically found all of them on Stack
Overflow so basically this is what I
wanted to talk about I tried to show two
things the first is I think that there's
a need and also a feasible solution for
having a library that basically wrapped
so I could learn on the fly and gives it
and s capabilities it makes the code
that is safer it's more interpretable it
allows to combine estimators better or
at least more succinctly and the more
complex things you do with it for
example if you do nested cross
validation or things like that and the
more you're basically going to need
metadata and the natural way to send
metadata is through pandas dataframes
not not by haxxing inside numpy race so
the more you combine these things I
think there's more more of a need for it
and in the sense I think that that the
solution fits the current generation of
libraries which give a pandas interface
but have an implementation that works
over nampak so for example if we look at
the field of plotting plotting so we
have a map plot lab which works directly
over an empire but now we have newer
libraries such as mocha or Seabourn
which reuse the code inside matplotlib
but they work on pandas entities they
use the metadata so basically the
solution is the same and in terms of
implementation at least thought it was
interesting to see all the different
utilities that that Python gives us
there's this matte meta patch which
allows us to create different paths in
the way that new models are imported and
which allows us at one time to
introspect to model and inspect of
course and local classes and the pickle
protocol so the code is uh is really
ready to use and I'd really like to ask
you to use it and give us any feedback
you have in order to to make it better
you know just just feel free to open
issues or anything or if you want to
contribute I'll be extremely happy I
think it's really time to have machine
learning library that's built over data
frames so that's it basically I thank
you very much yes
so that's an okay so the question was
why why change the way to combine
estimators and not not reuse the
scikit-learn
solution so that's an excellent question
it's actually an orthogonal part because
you can use all of the Metis that all of
the metadata stuff without doing that
and I'd like to emphasize that it's
completely optional you can continue to
use make pipeline make a union and so I
personally find them less fun you know
if you just have a Jupiter notebook and
you want to try out things quickly it's
a lot a lot of typing I think relative
to what it ends with but it's possible
to continue using those functions with
these classes it's not not a problem
Thanks yes yes absolutely the question
was is it possible to pass multi index
and and the answer is yes yes yes that's
an excellent point and in fact this was
I think the first motivation for me you
can use the metadata inside the index to
perform more complex things in internal
stages like making stratified or labeled
cross validations or stacking there was
an interesting stacking talk yesterday
so it's actually designed for that and
if you have such these cases I'll be
really happy to know if it works for you
conveniently or otherwise and if not you
know please please open an issue and say
well any other question yes
right that that's also an excellent
question dill dill
there's a pickling much better than
pickle does and why not just use dill so
this goes a bit beyond my knowledge of
Python but as far as I know it it's
really a bit risky to assume that you're
using deal because it involves a certain
order where you're importing things and
I just didn't want to rely on that but I
agree with you that basically it's it's
a better idea to use dill than pickle
directly in fact from looking in the
code it seems to me the circuit learning
itself is using dill internally and job
lived and stuff like that okay if
there's no more question so thank you
very much for your time
[Applause]